[Music]
so why should someone who's in the
business of getting someone's attention
why should someone who runs a business
that's all about getting attention why
should they switch to being in the
business of helping people well for one
it's gonna be hard to do that until
consumers actually demand that that's
what they want we all need to recognize
just as citizens of humanity just being
human that this world that's constantly
fighting to grab our attention doesn't
serve any of us it's it's it's polluting
our inner and our social lives and once
we recognize that that's that we don't
want that as consumers that will enable
businesses to follow consumer demand and
say we want to provide something whose
goals are entirely in alignment with
your goals where we measure our success
in terms of the net positive benefits
that we delivered in people's lives and
we charged more like a subscription
model or a payment model rather than
advertising where we have an infinite
appetite in stealing as much of your
attention as possible so you know when
we check our phones 150 times a day
which is the average are those 150
conscious moments where we're sitting
here and then we think and then we
choose now I'm gonna check my phone or
does it just happen to us and I think
one thing that that we don't talk about
with the attention economy what's
different about the attention economy
versus a normal marketing product goods
economy is that in the regular economy
people make a conscious choice
theoretically about the products that
they choose to buy or the places I
choose to go to I have to get into a car
and go there in the attention economy I
don't choose where my attention goes I
choose kind of in the moments in between
but a lot of my attention can be steered
this is what magicians do I mean they
they do a trick by steering your
attention by focusing your attention
over here and so what's different about
the attention economy is we have less
choice about where our attention goes it
can be steered and manipulated much more
easily than the conscious choice buying
economy where I'm choosing to buy a good
so so yeah so why are we checking our
phones 150 times a day why is this so
compelling well it's because at any
given moment in life when when I am left
with the uncomfortabie against just a
little bit boring for just a moment if
you have just a break you you walk into
a cafe and there's a line before you
order what do we do why do we pull out
our phone in that moment in a world
where this has increasingly you know
gives you access to anything that you
want at any given moment or the ability
to get back to those 10 emails or the
ability to watch that video you've been
meaning to watch why would you not turn
to your phone in that free moment so we
have to reckon with a world in which
next door to my current moment-to-moment
experience of reality there's this
immediately sweeter better choice and if
that's true for every human being
walking around we just put a better
choice on life's menu in your pocket
that at any moment you can switch to
suddenly the world's gonna look a lot
like it does today where everyone is
down in their phones right and it's it
the point isn't that suddenly were you
know just distracted or something like
that that we have to really get intimate
with why is this happening and the
reason it's happening is because it's
more compelling than simply being with
the discomfort of reality as it is which
is going to force us to ask some really
deep questions with with ourselves of if
we were to not live that way if we were
to live not looking at our phone in a
free moment in time would we be willing
to deal with sometimes being a little
bit uncomfortable or being a little bit
bored and when we make that choice we
don't just make that alone because you
know imagine that person who you know
meditates in the morning and suddenly
says you know I really I'm not gonna
look at my phone today and so they they
stand they land in that line in the cafe
and they don't look at their phone and
they're kind of looking around smiling
but suddenly everything around them is
still on their phone and what what it
really realizes is that you know it's
sort of like a weekend isn't just for us
it's about being in a weekend together
if we don't look at our phone we don't
just want to not look at our phone by
ourselves we'd want to actually be able
to connect together and we're connecting
with other people it makes realities as
sweet
as the things that our phone provides
because the whole point is like when
when you're in connection with someone
else and you're that actually is more
compelling than being with our phones
but when you're just by yourself sorting
for what's gonna be the most stimulating
or productive or entertaining way for me
to be right now oftentimes our phone
will beat out other choices that are
appearing before us and it's only when
we're with other people that and we're
in connection or conversation with
someone else that that actually is
better than often you know these
individual choices we can get on the
phone because we actually do desire
connection wouldn't
[Music]